We are going to go next to but just to keep
it going in the United States.
I do want to let our American friends get
in on here.
Let's go to Tyler from Austin, Texas.
The new home of Joe Rogan.
Tyler, what is it like having Joe Rogan in
town?
You know, I hear a lot of complaints about
it, but it doesn't really bother me.
It is what it is now very much wanted to hear
and contribute to the economy.
And I'm fine with it.
Go home about yet.
What's on our mind?
So my question is about something I've been
doing a little bit of investigating into is
the opinions that a lot of conservative media
pundits have held about Trump in the past
back in the 2016 election.
Right.
They said extremely disparaging things about
him and they were in full recognition that
he was a racist, even like an anti-Semite.
So on and so forth.
And what I'm really concerned about is following
this election, even if Trump loses, what is
going to stop?
What are conservatives going to reflect and
realize that the candidate has gone too far?
That even though he has the effect that they
want on their base, ginning up support, that
he is too out of left field, that he is too
awful of a person.
When are they going to have a moment of reflection?
I don't see that happening right now.
I don't see them realizing the situation that
they've gotten themselves into.
Well, there is a lot of cognitive dissonance
that prevents people from having that awakening.
And so I think that only if Donald Trump brutally
loses.
I'm talking about landslide loss and Republicans
lose the Senate.
I mean, if there is a real repudiation of
everything Republicans are in stand for at
the Senate and White House level, will you
see some Republicans say that was really disastrous.
That can never happen again.
But otherwise, I think you'll see, even if
Trump loses, a lot of Republicans chalk it
up to Corona virus.
A lot of Republicans chalk it up to bad timing.
And I would be shocked if there was any kind
of serious self-examination that you're taught
or a reckoning of sorts.
I doubt it.
I just don't think you're going to see it
because I'm worried about somebody who's just
as bad as Trump or even worse in the future
copyright law.
And being legitimized just like he has.
And I can't see a reason why they wouldn't
do that since he has been a really reliable
vehicle.
Like I said, and like you've said before,
for ginning up that support and like racial
a bit of Corker said, for activating his base.
You're completely right.
If they go against him, then they cancel out
that section of the electorate and they have
to figure out a way to move left, which I
can't see them doing that.
No, I think that, in fact, it it would take
some very accurate politicking for several
election cycles to get past the risk that
very soon a Trump number two comes forward.
And whether it's one of his kids or whether
it's someone else.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But we're gonna have to work really hard to
prevent that.
And step removing Trump with and replacing
them with Biden is just the first step of
many.
I've seen Norman Ornstein and I don't know
if you know who that is, the political scientist.
He says that the Republicans need to lose
three elections in a row in a landslide in
order for them to have this reckoning that
we're in.
That's my instinct.
I think.
I think that he's right.
Yeah.
OK.
Well, thank you so much for the call.
Kind of really caught me off guard.
That just slid it over.
Appreciate it.
Tyler Tyler from Austin, Texas.
Great to hear from you.
We're going to go next to where are we going
next?
Let's go to our friend Sasha from Montreal,
one of my favorite, favorite cities in the
world.
I would even say Sasha from Montreal, you
can go ahead and yeah, let me know what's
on your mind today.
Well, I was kind of disappointed yesterday.
To be fair, yeah.
Only I was really disappointed.
I just the interruption by the kids.
He couldn't talk.
He couldn't.
It was crazy places.
Yeah.
I just shut it off, watched it like it was
just that was really hard for.
But sorry, you were hyper or you were.
Hi.
Oh, can I.
All right.
I know some people who were both, but.
Yeah.
No, I understand.
I mean, are you.
Do you.
Do you imagine you'll watch the next debates?
I mean, probably you got nothing better to
do, I guess.
Yeah.
All right.
Anything else for me, Sasha?
No, really?
No.
You ever go to Saint via tour bagel in Montreal?
I don't think so.
I recommend it.
I don't actually live there, I live in the
suburbs.
Oh, you're in the suburbs, I say.
Yeah.
All right, Sasha.
Very good.
I appreciate the phone call.
OK.
All right.
There is Sasha from Montreal.
Very good, understated phone call.